you've done films that are
sci-fi like gattaca and other films that
touch on war themes
this is a war themed movie but a very
different kind of war
uh yeah we've never had a war like this
before i mean ethan hawke's character
tommy egan
uh we're they're going to be a lot more
tommy egans because we're going to go to
war at home
and uh we've never done that before we
we don't know what the toll is going to
take on those soldiers uh so but that's
the going to be the new normal you know
when when
bruce greenwood's character says you
know we're ordering more drones than
jets
that's the
case we look at films war films in that
genre on a spectrum of pro-war or
anti-war you've got the green berets on
the other end you may have platoon
does this film fit in there at all
uh
maybe not uh because i don't think it's
one of those
easy answers you know you can't say you
can't for instance say that you're
anti-drone
it would be like saying you're anti the
internet
you know because
it's they're not going anywhere it is
the new sort of schizophrenia of war
that we're going to have
there was a lot of news coverage and i'm
sure that you read it about the new
drone program and the sense of
triumphalism or the high-fiving that we
got this guy or that guy but then there
started to be the stories about the
ethan hawk kind of characters at home
and i bet it's that dissonance perhaps
that attracted you
yeah i mean
for instance ethan's character you know
normally when he was in an f-16 before
you know the events of the film
uh he would drop his ordinance and fly
away
but now we're asking him to drop his
ordinance and just sit there and watch
and do what they call damage assessment
which is
more accurately is counting the dead
and we've never asked anybody to watch
that in high def and just sit there and
see the destruction they caused there's
so much visual drama in the way that
drone warfare is waged did you have to
change anything enhance anything for the
sake of the story or was it all there
for you uh my design philosophy with
this movie was no design
it just i just wanted to be completely
accurate and that's why i used
x drone pilots to make it as authentic
as possible
how forthcoming were they when you
talked to them uh
you know on the nuts and bolts of
teaching someone how to fly from seven
thousand miles away they were they were
you know very um forthright but
when
it came to the questions about the cia
i would you know even when i got them
drunk i would say
so you've flown missions for the cia
right and they would say we can't talk
about that they had another acronym they
used ogas yes other government agencies
three letters sounds like exactly yeah
but they were yeah they were they would
not utter cia
there was a lot of resistance in in
acknowledging for a while that these
guys were pilots that they could suffer
ps ptsd questions did they get purple
hearts for sitting there at a console
yeah i no they uh they were going to
award a medal for drone operators and
there was such an outcry from the rest
you know from other branches of the
military who said you know no no we give
medals for acts of valor and courage
you know if you're just sitting like we
are you know in absolutely no you know
no danger we're not going to give a
medal for that but the flip side of that
was so they didn't award it but the flip
side was
well hold on you just said to these guys
that even though you're making life and
death decisions
uh we're not going to recognize that
that's just not worth recognizing
so you know it's uh how do you go to
work that day
was it difficult to get financing for a
film that could have been interpreted as
so critical of the american war effort
it's it's strange you say that because
um
i've been accused of being anti-american
in europe i was accused of being too
pro-american then you must have gotten
it right
hope maybe maybe yeah i was um i know
you know because it's an uncomfortable
truth that i'm telling i
never expected a mainstream uh studio to
get involved
you've worked with ethan hawk for a
number of years on a number of projects
was this a different experience or did
you click did you get
right back in each other's heads as i'm
sure you were in earlier films
oh yeah whenever ethan needs a haircut
he comes to me
because he's he's naturally a very
grungy looking guy but you know i've
made him an astronaut and garrick and i
made him interpolage and
you know and uh now he's a he's a
fighter pilot
but the thing was i couldn't have made
this film without ethan because now we
have such a
shorthand it's kind of got beyond that
it's almost a sort of telepathy
you know i'll he'll do a take and i'll
want to make an adjustment and i'll take
one step towards him and he'll go no no
no i know what you want me to do and um
he'll do it so it's getting kind of
spooky working with him
there is necessarily a claustrophobia
to a lot of the scenes in this did you
try to make sure that that was conveyed
to the viewer as well as to the person
who would be sitting in that little
cubicle in the desert
yeah i think it was
unavoidable really but you know what i
did was to
sort of open it out a little bit i just
always went inside the monitor so you
never saw the frame of it and so
like ethan hawke's character and zoe
kravitz's character you were sort of
sucked into afghanistan or yemen or
waziristan
so uh that was an important thing for me
you did a lot of filming in morocco was
there any sense of awkwardness because
you were making a movie about people
living in the desert getting bombed from
above in the desert
well they did they did ask me
when i then they heard the title they
said good kill
is there such a thing you know
and um of course good kill just for
anyone who doesn't know of course it's
it is the is what you say when you there
is a successful strike it's nothing i
made up in fact none of the language i
made up but um it was a challenging
thing
actually shooting the drone footage
which i modeled uh on wikileaks
footage because that's the only way you
get to see a drone strike
but it was it was kind of tricky
even doing a location scout because i
realized that i couldn't be on the
ground
since the drone
pilots were never on the ground
you know they were 7 000 miles away i
always had to be above
and um you know the moroccans would
drive me into a town and they'd say so
what do you think and i'd say i don't
know yet you know because i have to have
to get up
in the air to look at it you know so i
had to have a cherry picker
to even location scout
as i was watching i was looking at the
scenes stateside where you had almost
the same kind of tracking shots of an
american car and an american military
guy and it made me uneasy because you
know the drones are up there and google
earth is up there that somebody's always
watching
yeah no it was that was uh intentional
that you know i know that ethan's
character has this god's eye point of
view but i wanted to carry that through
in vegas as well
on top of that there was some other
god